it's great to be joined today by Julian
DeWitt who is a researcher at MIT who is
leading the atmospheric study of the
Trappist one planets which we spoke
about I guess now it's been a couple of
weeks right since the big press release
about these planets how long have you
been working on this I've been working
on the this one system is Miguel's you
know when the Cubs team for now over at
you and what initially tipped you off to
to the possibility that these planets
could be well number one terrestrial and
possibly even earth-like in terms of
habitability temperature etc at what
point in the process was that something
you started exploring well the
terrestrial aspect is something that
came first right when you look for
planets using the transit technique
meaning when you look for this dim of
light when something is passing in front
of a star it tells you about the size of
the planet gives you what we call the
planet two star array a ratio so as soon
as we could measure the tip then we knew
that they were earth sized so the idea
that that could be terrestrial while
they are in the first place as soon as
they were discovered now for their
potential habitability you the fact that
we know the temperature of the star of
the star and how far the planet are told
us immediately that there were temperate
enhance potentially habitable so it was
quick now what is great is that we don't
really know but given to us is soon
let's talk a little bit about the
distance of this system from Earth we've
heard the the figure 37 to 40
light-years thrown around of course
Lightyear is a distance the distance
that light can travel in a year talk to
us about in practical terms in a way
that maybe will be understandable to the
average human mind how far this is the
human mind it is you know it is very
difficult to picture so that I'm not
sure we'll be able to to help but what
is what we should do is try to put this
the context of
about universe or even our galaxy is
this really in the neighborhood of our
seven the closest star to us is Proxima
Centauri and Proxima Centauri is four
light-years away this one cut this one
is about 40 light years away which is
just ten times further what what matters
at this stage really is that it is
closed this is relatively close to us
that it can provide us with this new
perspective on terrestrial planets this
may not answer your question but to
bring this a bit further and what's
interesting is that this star is one of
the the star type is one of the most
frequent in our galaxy again so we find
that this star let us know that can live
almost forever might have lots of
tourists really on its meaning that what
we thought to be well the archetype of
terrestrial planet kind of like ours
like Venus like ours may not be easy I
drew the archetype like a typical
historical Taurus your planet might be
the planet like the Trappist one and
it's really nice to have this one at
hands within reach with future Atrisco
so we can study them in hands maybe
completely change our perspective
terrestrial planets habitats on such
planets and and live it you know I'd
love to dig into some of the
characteristics that you're sort of
alluding to here you have planets that
are tightly packed around a star that is
cooler than our Sun it's smaller than
our Sun can you talk to us a little bit
about what the sort of implications of
that are for the planets surrounding the
star yes well what's what's interesting
about so as I said the star is is really
small really cold actually a core to a
point where you even see water in the
emission spectra of the star so that is
something that that is really exciting
by itself and because the star is so
small in so cold
rather than I mean the planet being far
away from it they are really tightly
packed around it meaning that what we
call the habitable zone which is a
concept which is the place where it is
most likely for a planet to be able to
to
quit water into other surface it's also
very close to its star and so this
planet that are potentially habitable
found very close to one another so if
you were to have life to appear on one
of them it's interesting to wonder how
life could exchange or move from one
planet to the next because
interplanetary travel on such planet
would not last months you know you know
as it would in the solar system the
bells so close to another that it would
only take days now if you put this back
in the perspective of how much exchange
there has been between a planet like
Mars and the earth we can find Martian
rocks here because they've been ejected
by impact is consumed interesting to see
how much exchanges being of materials
and potentially organic material from
one planet end and the other in in such
a system so the idea of a multi-planet
biosphere could be something was
investigating as well so and you said
that travel between these planets could
take just a few days is that based on
current technology that we have on earth
is that how that is considered yes okay
because of the proximity to the star the
a year on some of these planets could
last anywhere from you know an earth day
and a half to 20 earth days so to speak
what about the duration of a day on
these planets which of course is not
dependent on on the distance from the
star but also the rotation of the planet
do we know anything about that yet so
that's an excellent question
that is if anything actually your Zadok
would just last forever but what we
think is a the the closest of the planet
are likely tidally locked meaning that
they're always present the same face to
their star exactly like that with the
earth the moon turn around the earth in
the same amount of time that it turns
around itself so it just always show the
same face to the to the earth right so
it's the same thing for this planet into
the about the aside comin on right side
so it also means that you stand if you
ending at any point on the planet the
star will always be at the same position
in the sky so there will be no day per
se there will be no day and night and
that is for all of the planets that
you've identified so far every single
one has this lack of rotation so to
speak we do not know so they do rotate
but in the same amount of time if there
are two yes no way to be right I
misspoke yeah but we don't know that's
something that we would have to
investigate it is quite likely for the
one that know that closest to the star
because of the day that interaction for
the other one this would have to be
investigated that we really know soot
down lots of you know question mark that
still need to be answered but all of
these are going to be taken serum
whenever we have an announcement like
this very quickly the conversation comes
up of could there be could there be some
form of life on some of these planets we
don't have that answer yet of course but
my question is at our distance nearly 40
light-years away
how can you try to figure out whether
there may be some form of life on one of
these planets what are the techniques
that are used well it currently so so
really the community is so excited that
we we have initiated an F for grounding
from the x-ray violet down to radio and
this will allow us to look at the planet
in different ways in ultraviolet we're
looking for atmospheric escape exosphere
and so in using these wavelengths but
also the infrared be able to search
cisterna the exosphere as the atmosphere
of the planet and so we can search for
what we call biosignatures which are
signs of life or sets of galaxies that
could indicate the presence of a biomass
now in radio we're looking for signs of
magnetic field but also I guess you're
familiar with the movie contact with
Jodie Foster Goryeo so essentially we
may potentially stumbled upon structure
to reach a signal and we actually
corresponding now is set in director
that may be another way to search for
signs of life more advanced form of life
history well it's absolutely fascinating
these these must be exciting days in
your lab right it is exciting
I don't have to have seen yesterday the
the kids who did as a capital of the
Kepler space telescope provided access
to three months of continuous
observation of the Cubbies one system
and the whole I mean a good sense of
like our community
we're just crunching the data Addison
Simon tweeting about the results over
there so now everyone really is imported
with everyone is joining this new
venture it's it's really a new a new era
for specification and and that is
exciting we have like seven beautiful
targets in hands and maybe more to come
so yeah it is a terrific time for us one
one last thing I noticed in preparing
for the interview that you studied in
Liege and in Belgium and the planets are
named the Trappist planets and of course
Belgium known for Trappist beers is
there any connection here in the naming
and your background in Belgium or am i
is this just coincidence which so the
principal investigator of kapust and
speculoos so the naming in doors goes
beyond campus because speculoos which is
the project for which this is a
prototype speculoos is an another
typical bench and biscuits and make it
elevator in finding acronyms that would
lead to interesting interesting names
and now nice built-in hint in history
theory with the discovery of this one so
that is that is all of this is coming
straight from an occasional not a
coincidence okay good to know we've been
talking with we've been speaking with
Julian de Wit
researcher at MIT working on this very
exciting project thanks so much for
talking to us about this thank you